today's topic people though this energy
broke when you're dating somebody okay
you guys need to learn how to about your
dating lives people are too gossipy
gossipy about every detail with people
that they've dated they go tell their
friends everything now I'm gonna talk
about women
cuz I only date when I'm dating you I'm
showing you an intimate part of myself
and you go to your friends and you tell
them everything and you don't think
that's a violation of my privacy who
shares more with their friends men or
women I just feel like girls have more
like details and really and more
reactions to it because they're more
open with their feelings and about
information guys they can I just say
something
did a man just assume that all of his
girlfriend's female friends know
everything about him my friend knows
everything every little detail have you
ever had a friend share something about
her boyfriend you felt was inappropriate
I'm oversharing
no I mean I think of it like unlike
they're comfortable with me but not like
okay that's too much he's like Oh mache
and it's like after a while it just like
gets to Dean yeah kind of like it can be
kind of weird what they say but I don't
really find that because we're all just
like poking about I don't really think
that any topic is inappropriate among
friends a friend shares with me would be
because I'm always open if anyone wants
to like say anything to me I don't
really want to like judge them and say
like over like that's too much they
shouldn't be telling me that do you ever
get nervous about what details and
manuals you're dating shared with his
friend yeah it's just like I don't want
my business to be out there and I don't
want them to know it literally
everything about me it's like I'm
comfortable with him only so it's like
it everyone knows that about me the like
what's our special relationship yeah
definitely if anybody's like talking
about me like if that just makes you
nervous I don't really think that any
topic is inappropriate among friends I
don't think anything that a friend
shares me would be because oftentimes we
feel like man why don't you open up more
do I want all your friends who I'm not
dating to know my business men why don't
you trust us more you can't be trusted
with a few great that's what I didn't
sign up for you to tell everyone else if
you had told me a secret in confidence
like I have never not once ever thought
I'm gonna tell my friends that details
that they tell me but ladies apparently
you just feel comfortable just sharing
all these details and I'm just like
where do you get off like the audacity
to you know with the tea I think what he
went and told the whole world about his
daughters gynecology and her private
thing you can't be out there and talk
about but yeah but you do it you do it
often and your justification as girls
talk I'm good because I know where my
self-esteem just I'm fine but a dude who
isn't in it rough if he finds out that
everyone here it goes another man trying
to mansplain some woman how they should
you know what the only time I've ever
mentioned like an actual name to my
friends about like someone I was seeing
with the only time I've ever done it
right is when the girl was legitimately
like crazy one of my friends was gonna
date her then I was like yell Bravo
watch out - she did this to me and I
just wanna warn you cuz I don't want you
to be in a bad situation give you the
8th of base I mean that's it
otherwise I keep most of names private
because that's an intimate experience
that they shared with me not with me and
my friends mm-hmm I guess you know girls
will be girls when women are talking
with their friends about men that
they're dating how much detail do they
go into
a lot a lot everything you go into as
much detail as possible with your
friends so that they can give you some
kind of objective everything would men
be shocked if they overheard women talk
about men cuz a lot of my friends are
girls and I'm shocked most of the time
cuz you sat in with us in our guy group
compared to it the ladies yeah cuz I got
really I have both yeah I have our guy
group right and I have the rest like but
punch my friends and Joe guys like go
right then you know whatever I think
went wrong well what happened I said
something what'd you say said oh really
well that's bad man whatever they didn't
okay move on girl
okay so what happened was he picked me
up around 7:00 7:30 door 1 7:25 so like
when I get there I get down the stairs I
was wearing my blue dress you know I
know when I like you know from New
Year's the curve the coloration the
discoloration the tastes that everything
they go into everything into every
single bit of it the guys pants not so
much very big about that if you're a guy
and you go with a girl with a girl you
just met and you meet her friends and
like oh hi
they know everything that girl oh hi
excuse me your name is Jason Jason
she knows if you're a girl you meet your
guy friends the guys are gonna be like
that's a girl you just that's most of
all all we know yeah you know having one
time I laid the pipe really good I met
her friend I was like hey my name is aya
she went I know
that's pretty much what it is you know
kills me it's like I gave the girl I was
seeing like first degree but then her
friends got second degree
Oh breaking arts when they went I know
it was creepy and subtle but we had to
move past I'm not gonna let it sit in
this moment but it was so like oh she
knows everything yes everything but that
guy you step in with you
you know everything well scientifically
they're just as likely books are just as
likely to costume
yeah if with women far longer and women
far more details one thing we're not
saying that man don't do it your mouth
of detail and the death of the detail
that they going through is really you
and women know this is true you know I
know this is true because 70% of women
me at the workplace are by other
women in terms of workplace gossip
character assassination this is well
documented most women who report at work
reported from other female co-workers
some of the meanest things that they've
had to here are from other women you
don't touch the fat energy you are on
your page I can give advice to women
it's as a guy if I look at you and I
look who you hang out with and your
friends are sloppy and loud and is your
friends see pop ocg church basket I know
I know that you're gonna go and sloppy
sloppy Johanna and rattle everything and
floppy Johanna is sloppy so she's gonna
slop away you know I mean so there's it
reduces your chances I'm
it's a violation of I know it is you
know what it is so I think we talked
about before it's like consideration way
but you mean you want to go through life
not being a nuisance of it yeah so when
a girl comes to me if she asks yeah I'm
trying to let her off as easy as
possible
time's a-wastin yes I don't want her ego
to be damaged they want her to be ready
yeah or whatever next one he hasn't no
we're not trying to traumatize people
you know I think probably the biggest I
think scary thing about rejection or any
of that stuff is like it's not even the
rejection from the woman it's everyone
else around Oh everybody's watching
right
nobody's watching but on that it's like
oh you know perfect example I went up to
a girl right somewhere on you and I was
like yo you want to go and do some top
she's like nah took that L on my
forehead that's two weeks later on top
of some other girl say yo I heard you
asked her out and I won't say who told
you that like she did she's been telling
everyone know there's a lot of girls
it's a trophy to say no to that you
don't know ask me out the other day who
that guy that guy that guy and I said no
I can bro it's like you're not special
I wanted to smash him - I was like yo
you're trying to do it - and you like
not but I moved on but then you had to
go and act like it was a giant deal
it'd be like me applying got McDonald's
I get rejected and then McDonald's like
you won't believe when we reject her for
a job it's like why would you do that
and like I could handle it because of
the fact that you know from yeah I got
at least some self-esteem so like they
didn't bother me that other people on
you but it did made me think of her
differently and I was like how low-class
do you have to be to share that
information like if we'd slept together
I would not have gone to everyone to be
like y'all you want to know who I
smashed like that's not something I
would have done I would have not put
your name out there even my best friends
like I've encountered boom booms that
smell so bad that I gotta do the fat
Jolene back when I'm hitting it cuz like
it and and I would never ever think of
going down a but you're giving it all ya
know and I would never think of wanna
run to gossip about those details about
that girl because I already know that
women are already self-conscious enough
about this as it is so I would not
want to ruin that reputation for her
make her feel terrible right so me I
just thought it was
so immature them that you went to gossip
to everybody and I asked I'm like yo are
you gone around telling everybody he's
like yeah well you know what it is a
girls talk just just calm down for real
dude like here you're putting this out
of proportion it was just no locker room
talk so quick shout out to Alexander
Grace he's the one who did a lot of this
interview footage he runs a good YouTube
channel so if you want to check out more
interviews like the one he was doing
with those girls be sure to check out
his channel
[Music]